- You see my gross feet?
Well, I guess they're not that bad,
but I've often sat here
wondering what it'd be like
to have soft, smooth feet
that I could rub my hands over
like it's a dove commercial.
So when I came across these
foot peeling masks on TikTok,
I was like, "Ooh, tell me more".
So I sent these foot masks for myself
and two friends to see
whether they work or not.
And to see whether all that
skin peeling is worth it.
Now be warned, this is
going to peel my skin off.
It's not going to happen immediately.
I'm going to have to wait a few days
but this is going to peel my skin off.
Viewer discretion is advised.
(transition music)
- I have seen these on
TikTok very briefly.
I hate gross TikTok's.
So if anything shows up like that
I just scroll past really fast.
- When we were young, we used to put like,
glue on our hands, then peel it off.
I don't know why, but
that's what this foot peel
reminds me of.
- [Joelle] People joke about, you know,
charging for videos of their feet.
But here I am doing it for free.
Definitely have some calluses
right on this part of my foot.
Don't know how they got there.
Don't know how to get rid of them.
- I do have some rough feet.
So, I'm really hoping that this works.
- I'm kind of scared to do this.
- Wait, what?
- Oh, this feels weird.
- [Destiny] Now I just have
to let my feet marinate.
- [Joelle] It feels like
I'm in a kitty pool full
of like oobleck or something.
- Oh yeah, I guess I'll check
back in, in a couple of days
when anything starts
happening, see you later.
- I just played tennis.
And when I took my socks off
skin started flaking out of
my socks and onto the ground,
and I can see my skin is starting to peel.
- That is my skin stuck to my sock.
Oh my God.
That's so gross.
- My feet are doing
something kind of weird.
They're kind of shiny.
And they feel really tight.
Especially on top of my feet.
The skin is really dry and really shiny.
Something's definitely happening.
- See that, oh they're so dried out.
Oh yes.
- Oh. You know, just minding
my business in public
with my feet shedding.
- The peeling actually
kind of peaked there
and it never got a full peel.
The back of the package
says that if you have
tougher skin, it may
not exfoliate as much.
And that you can try a second application.
So right now I've got
a second set on my feet
and I'm going to give it another week.
See how that does for me.
I just really want my feet to peel, okay.
- My calluses looked worse than before.
I feel like people are staring at my feet.
I'm over this foot peel.
They look very scary
and I am just hoping that it gets better.
- [Dakota] Okay now we're
starting to get some results.
Look at that.
Now that is the kind of
peeling I am looking for.
- It's not coming off
in like one big chunk
but it's starting to like
flake and peel like a corpse.
(transition music)
- Okay, so it's been just about a week
and my feet they're still peeling,
but they're pretty smooth.
- Holy feet!
Look at that.
You see that? My feet are so soft now.
I can't stop touching them.
- It's past the number of days
that the peel said it needed to work
and my foot never fell off.
The peeling that you see
in those viral TikTok's
where the whole like exterior
part of your skin falls off
to reveal like that baby
smooth skin underneath
that never happened to me.
There was some peeling
around parts of my foot
that were already kind of
calloused and gross and dead
but I'm pretty disappointed
that I didn't get
baby butt, soft feet by
the end of this thing.
So I'm very sorry for anyone
who's hoping to see my
little foot carcass.
- My feet are so soft.
I didn't think that my feet
would ever stop peeling.
And they're still peeling a little bit.
My calluses were so rough and
cracked and dry and gross.
And they're so like smooth.
And like it's, this foot
peel is literally magic.
Go get it.
- My feet are very soft.
They feel very nice.
And that peeling was very satisfying.
So I recommend this to anyone.
If you do this wear socks to
bed, it may be uncomfortable
but otherwise you're going
to wake up with a bunch
of skin flakes in your
bed and you're going to
have to vacuum your sheets in the morning,
which is not something
people normally need to do.
Have you ever peeled your feet like this?
Let us know in the comments
down below and a link
to check out the mask we use
will be in the description.
Thank you so much for watching.
And I will talk to you
guys in the next one.
Bye-bye.
I'm probably going to end
up on a foot fetish website.
Aren't I?
(outro music)